hello everyone peter brown here with a
gamespot news update dice has just
informed us that battlefield hardline
has been delayed until 2015 the vp and
group GM of dice released a statement on
the battlefield blog explaining their
reasons for the unexpected delay
according to the statement feedback that
the developer received during the beta
has caused them to start thinking about
other possibilities in ways they could
push hard line innovation further and
make the game even better but in order
to do so dice said it needs more time
the statement lists three improvements
that the company hopes to implement with
the extra time the first is multiplayer
innovation including ideas direct from
the community that will evolve the cops
and criminals fantasy into a truly
unique battlefield multiplayer
experience dice also wants to flush out
the single-player story including
polishing the core features as well as
adding new ones that will support a
deeper crime revenge story experience
and finally the team wants to improve
stability saying that they have learned
a lot from battlefield 4 and will
continue to learn from another hardline
beta the extra time will allow them to
fix more issues before launch the
statement also mentions that dice
continues to work on battlefield 4 the
dragon's teeth DLC is coming out July 29
with more DLC plan for later in the year
no word yet on the adjusted release date
other than early 2015 but for more
information on battlefield stay tuned to
gamespot com